pierre-alexandre bonjour alors on vous
retrouve comme il ya deux semaines où
vous nous expliquer l'histoire du
bitcoin et les raisons de son succès
aujourd'hui vous revenez sur le sujet un
décrypte monnaie en vous penchant plus
précisément sur les réactions à des
institutions face au développement de
ces monnaies électroniques
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
et bonjour nathalie olivier alors
recommencer on peut rappeler brièvement
le téléspectateur ce que sont les crypto
monnaie il s'agit de monnaie virtuelle
cryptée indépendante entièrement créé
par informatique et leur porte-étendard
et le désormais célèbre bitcoin c'est
une ses croissants des crypto monnaies
suscite la méfiance de certains acteurs
économiques plus traditionnels comme les
banques centrales ou et multinationales
et leurs réactions ou de la volonté de
réguler au désir de créer leur propre
monnaie virtuelle et certaines
personnalités du monde économique ont
d'ailleurs exprimé publiquement leur
méfiance à l'égard de ces crypto monnaie
oui tout à fait on peut par exemple
citer l'ancienne présidente de la banque
centrale américaine janet yellen qui a
déclaré le mois dernier que le bitcoin
était un actif hautement spéculatifs et
qu'elle s'inquiétait des pertes
potentielles que les investisseurs
pourraient subir on peut également citer
l'économiste français benoît coeuré qui
est allé jusqu'à affirmer que le bitcoin
était une émanation magnifique de la
crise financière de 2008 ou encore le
célèbre milliardaire bill gates qui a
quant à lui déclaré qu'il n'était pas
optimiste sur les bitcoins en
considérant en conseillant par don de
faire attention aux personnes et en
moins d'argent calonne musk c'est à dire
tout le monde sauf jeff bezos
et face à un ses critiques elle les
pouvoirs publics souhaitent plus de
régulation mais cela inquiète les
défenseurs des crips nos bonnets oui en
effet ceux ci voient la régulation comme
une menace sur la liberté et
l'indépendance des crypto menée aux
états unis par exemple
l'administration a tenté en décembre
dernier d'introduire une obligation
d'enregistrer toutes les transactions de
plus de 10000 dollars depuis ou vers
l'équipe de monnaie est ce qui fait
craindre une immixtion du fisc et une
taxation de ces transactions et vous
avez donc évoqué la création nouvelle
crypto monnaie par des acteurs
économiques traditionnels de quoi
s'agit-il précisément pierre alexandre
et bien c'est crypto monnaies sont ce
qu'on appelle des styles qods s'agit de
réplique numérique de monnaies
fiduciaires comme l'euro où le dollar
dont le but est de protéger leurs portes
des fluctuations spéculative ces styles
causes peuvent être créées par des
entités privées comme facebook avec sa
monnaie les bras mais aussi par des
banques centrales
ça veut dire que les états pourraient
avoir leur propre crypto monnaie oui
tout à fait la présidente de la banque
centrale européenne estime mme lagarde a
par exemple évoqué à plusieurs reprises
le projet d'un euro numérique qui
pourrait voir le jour d'ici deux à
quatre ans 7 euros électronique serait
ni par la bce comme le sont aujourd'hui
les billets de banque et pourrait à
terme se substituer au cash
il faut savoir que de nombreux pays
travaillent sur des projets de crypto
monnaie publics tels que la russie la
chine ou les états unis
même si pensée dernier ce n'est pas une
priorité nous vous l'aurez compris les
crypto monnaie privée pionnières sont en
quelque sorte victimes de leur succès et
sont à la croisée des chemins soit ils
se normalise pour poursuivre une
croissance à grande échelle soit il
refuse les régulations et de meuron un
outil relativement marginal merci
beaucoup pierre alexandre faire les tic
pour toute explication je rappelle que
évidemment toutes ces précisions sur
l'écriteau monnaies sont à retrouver
dans votre article sur rt france pointe
et wc